so maybe we could talk a little bit
about these realistic Futures that we're
imagining that are more nuanced and that
are kind of a reaction against
um dystopia and so
um one thing that both of us are really
interested in and I want to toss this to
you to talk about first is
um having a really
um a canvas a temporal canvas that's
very broad like riding across a huge
span of time which here we are at the
long now which is devoted to that idea
so what is it about having that broad
time frame that you think lends itself
to a more nuanced vision of a of a
future world I think it's very simple I
have
um in all things I have a just an issue
with protagonists
um
because we don't have any like if you if
you really want to write something
realistic you don't have a protagonist
now granted I have written things with a
protagonist because with the novella
like you only have so much space
um
but uh I think if you really want to
paint a picture of a world where it is
more Cooperative where there is more of
a collective mindset where that thing is
perfect but things are working at least
better than here
um
it makes more sense in my mind to show
that this is a collective effort over
time and over
um you know often a large like
geographical space or Galactic space
depending on which books we're talking
about
um that you have multiple povs
um which we both like to play with in
our work
um because it's not just one person's
story there isn't going to be a savior a
chosen one who pulls us out of this it
you know I I am very intentionally
writing
um
to counter this idea of so you know the
the big genius that's going to save
everybody I think the people that are
going to save everybody are the very
ordinary people doing very very small
things
um to help each other and to be kind and
to be open to one another I think that
that's the only thing that's going to
push us forward is to have as much of
that as possible so those those are the
stories that I'm interested in telling
um because yeah if if
we're going to keep going the only way
to do it is together try it as that
sounds but that's the we're a social
species we have to do that
yeah and I think that's another aspect
of realism is acknowledging that we
actually are a collective and social
species and that it isn't going to be
you know
um Paula trades who like you know does
some drugs and like rides the worm right
I mean it's like it there's there's more
involved there's all the worm caretakers
there's all the people that are like you
know back home maintaining the family if
the world could be saved by a special
white boy doing drugs
[Laughter]
we would be there